[Applaudissements]
au fond de mon
grenier j'ai retrouvé une amourette d'un
soir
[Musique]
elle s'était envolé je ne sais plus
pourquoi je l'avais oublié depuis
longtemps
[Musique]
déjà dans un papier Jaun
recouvert de poussière son petit corps
mord reposait solitaire
[Musique]
elle était venue mourir dans ce décor
antique elle était venu mourir en
laissant pour
relique une mèche de
cheveux qu'elle m'avait donné
une mèche des
cheveux qu'un jour j'ai
calassé une mèche de
cheveux qui venait
ressuscité le souvenir d'un temps
heureux le dou mirage d'un
été le dou mirage d'un
été
[Musique]
je sentais ma mémoire prête à tout
raconter mais je connaissais l'histoire
j'ai préféré
[Musique]
rêver ce jour-là c'est étrange j'ai
voulu croire au fait mais pensé par un
ange je me suis
[Musique]
éveillé une mèche de
cheve qu'elle m'avait
donné une mèche mes
cheveux qu'un jour j'ai
caressé une mèche de
Chin qui venait
ressusciter le souvenir d'un temps
heureux le doux mirage d'un été
le doux mirage d'un
[Musique]
été